all the times Kanye upgraded Kim
Kardashian style Plus Serena Williams is
serving up some lemon happy hump day my
people I am on day three of this detox
you guys in not that you care but I'm
trying to make 2018 my year I sound
basic but I mean it I'm out here trying
to look my best okay but you know what
would help if I was married to Kanye
West it's no secret that Yeezy has
played a huge part in Kim's style
evolution part of me is convinced he
always wanted to marry someone he can
dress up but Kim doesn't seem to mind it
ever case in point
on Sunday's Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Kim revealed she has swapped
her once signature oversized glasses for
smaller frames that's right tiny glasses
are back and because while Kanye said so
[Music]
[Music]
like that
well Kanye's latest style input got me
thinking there have been quite a few
times Kanye upgraded Kim big-time like
the time Kanye and his stylist rated
Kim's closet and gave her a full
clothing makeover he should be not like
these yes but she might just keep this
for like my daughter one day and let's
not forget when Kim yay flew in another
designer last minute for their
bridesmaid dresses just days before
their wedding
I think when trying to figure out the
look connie sees a vision and there's
some things in florence that he has even
for a surprise for me so I definitely
want his input
now if Kanye is given that much input at
home or for their wedding then you know
there is not a red carpet look on Kim
that Kanye didn't have a say in in fact
at the 2015 Grammys that Gold sparkly
number Kim Rock yep that was all Kanye
how did you pick it out tell me the
whole process he actually picked this
out and sent me this look from a runway
show years ago and said we have to get
this so he stabbed me tonight and you
know sometimes business mixes with
pleasure
Kim revealed to us recently just how
influential her husband was which was
creating her k'kaw beauty fragrances
love to share one big bathroom because
it's when we get to talk and collaborate
and our lives are so busy and so I was
testing out a fragrance he walked by me
and the bathroom and was like what is
that I don't like that and I was like
this is one I was debating between and
this is the one I wasn't you know liking
and he confirmed it and then he said you
know what I really always want to smell
your fragrance cuz if you if this is the
one and I don't like it like this it'll
be a problem now as for whether Kanye
prefers his wife blonde or brunette Kim
told a fan on Twitter he prefers both
but maybe blonde so there you have it
you guys
the secret to looking as fab as Kim
Kardashian is to get your own Kanye West
so I'm gonna be ugly forever alright
moving on to someone who doesn't need
any help looking fierce Serena Williams
the tennis superstar grace is the cover
of vogue magazines february cover with
her baby girl alexis olympia now here's
what I love about Serena she's a beast
on the tennis court she can't work with
the best of them aka Beyonce and she
slayed us once again with her lemon
dance challenge for the magazine
[Music]
what I said what come on I don't care
what the tennis court the Grammy stage
I just need Serena Williams on
everything right can we get her there
now you know some folk who will be at
the 2018 Grammys Bruno Mars and cardi B
Kesha Luis FONSI and daddy yankee and
Souza are all on tap to perform at this
year's Grammy Awards they joined
previously announced performers Lady
gaga pink and childish gambino and that
all goes down on january 28th on CBS I
got to tell you I'm so excited because
next week I am with one of the dancers
from Bruno and cardis finesse video he's
gonna stop by and teach us the moves
okay so make sure you're subscribed to e
t--'s youtube channel so you guys don't
miss out I get it how many Oh stepping
on mics
you